- This is Agent 2021!
(serious music)
(funky music)
So I'm super excited like
obviously I do this a ton
but it's never been my party
right, I've just been a guest.
The maybe the guest of
honor, but always just guest,
and so to be the host,
and Kim is crushing it,
and the venue's insane,
hopefully you or Derock
or somebody will get
some sort of crazy angle
from up top, like it's
pretty fucking legit.
And everything is perfect.
And just cause I love
Steve Ross I will not razz
on the dolphins part of it all,
the irony of it all, but super excited.
- [Loudspeaker] Ladies and
gentlemen, please welcome
to the stage, the CEO of
VaynerX, Gary Vaynerchuk.
(audience cheering)
- You know, when I came up
with the concept of the name,
I thought it was interesting
to create a conference
that actually expires.
We, our ambition is to create
this brand, Agent 2021,
for people that we have as
agents, you know obviously
we pick the four sectors,
industries, that I think
what I'm about to keynote
about really matter,
the timing around my
new book, Crushing It,
and this talk, is very important,
because what is stunning
to me is how much opportunity
there is for everybody
at this conference, what
I think is super important
to really attack this
morning is I truly believe
that most of you don't understand
how big the stakes are,
because you get caught,
the way I get caught.
I don't believe that most of
us understand how early it is,
and I'm worried that you
haven't gone deep enough
while you're thinking about going wider.
You're doing well on
Facebook ads, or Google ads,
but you're leaving so
much more on the table.
I notice, because even I'm doing that.
If I can give you the
biggest pieces of advice,
that would be blanket,
that I know everybody could
be affected by, whether you
have a restaurant, or did,
whether you have a liquor
store, or did, whether you're
in the real estate business,
insurance, I know for fact,
for fact that you could
four to fifty times X,
your investment in both creative,
the pictures, the videos,
the written words, and in actually
spending the ads, to get far more.
The fact that you're
spending, and it's working,
is hiding the fact that there's
a lot more underneath that,
and I would really really really
take advantage of this morning
to set up, to set up the mindset,
for you to realize there's
probably a lot more going on in the depth,
then there is in the width.
Before you get get inspired,
to start your show,
your podcast, your Alexa
skill, what's going on
with Vine 2 when it comes
out, before you do that,
which you should, but I
feel like for most of us,
including myself, that
should be 20% of our energy
and mind, and 80% should
be looking very carefully
at what's working, and getting
far more committed to it.
This moment, right now, this
is how it's going to play out.
And I'm putting it on film,
and I'll look back at it.
This is the land grab of the Internet.
This is the land grab
to establish yourself
as the personality, the
authority, the organization,
the service in your industry,
still, you can have four
competitors who've got
more followers than you,
you can have people you look
up to that have crushed it,
and things of that nature that
will speak today, but still,
we haven't even come close,
so what does this all mean.
Here's how I think this plays out.
I genuinely believe that
80% and that includes people
that are more shy and
scared to be on camera,
and are introverted, I believe
that 80% of this audience,
over the next half-decade,
is gonna start debating
having a Derock, and an IRS, and a baben.
I think all of you over the
next decade will realize
that you are in the media
business, that before that you are
any kind of agent, you are
actually a show, that the shit
that you watch on Bravo
and HGTV and all the other
fucking channels, you
can do the same thing,
outside of the guy we
have here on his show
and about three other
shows, nobody really watches
any of these cable shows.
Literally the biggest thing
that's holding back the far
majority in this room, from
going into a completely
different level, financially,
and happywise, is the fact
that every year they're
just taking home too much
of the money they made,
and they're buying cars
and vacations and homes and
fucking bullshit jewelry.
If you're making money right
now, please re-invest it.
In the one thing that
doesn't get shattered during
a bad economy, which is your reputation.
I can't thank you enough for being here,
I am so excited about
Agent 2021, I am so humbled
that you guys are here, I
adore you, and I'm really
looking forward to seeing you guys
throughout the rest of the day.
Thank you.
(audience cheers)
- [Audience Member] Thank you for that.
That was like a game changer.
- Listen.
It's the point of this whole talk.
Like honestly while I've
got a lot of you listening,
cause it's a different feeling
then onstage, listen to me.
Nobody here is spending enough
money or time on this thing.
Nobody.
If I'm not, you're not even fucking close.
There's so much for you to take and I
just think everybody's checking the box.
You feel good that
you're on it, when you're
with your other friends,
because, you justify things like
I have 4,000 followers on
Instagram, it means dick.
Like you have to go all in.
This is like, rough.
I can feel the regret
building in my own body,
and I'm like literally
the leader of the whole
fucking thing, so where the fuck are you.
Please, please understand how big this is.
Yeah show a lot of different
tones, they've loved,
just kind of talk to
everybody like I'm talking
to like one person, a lot of
times I'm in showman mode,
I went way more mellow,
just like, plead, I was like
almost pleading, like right?
It was like a plea.
And it's a plea to all of
you, like please understand
how great this era is,
we're just not going hard
enough, fuck, think about it.
It's the Internet my friends,
it's the fucking Internet.
It's not him, or me, it's the Internet.
It eliminates everything
that has commodity.
This is about the fucking
Internet, and it can fucking
break your face unless you
ride the wave, because too many
of you are looking at
the wave coming at you,
and you think you're somebody
because you've had some
success, this thing is
gonna fucking kill you.
- Amen.
- I, I really am concerned
that people think that they're
doing social media and
marketing and building their
personal brand, and I think
that, that concerns me,
because I think there's
so much left to be had,
I think good enough is is just
a bad idea, oh it's because
you're not pushing yourself
and taking it there,
I think what I'm even
specifically focused on right now,
is there is underpriced
attention on social media,
that can be leveraged for your
success, for your happiness,
and so what I was kind of
ranting at, since the people
that came to this conference
are a little bit more educated,
is hey, I know that you have
an Instagram and a Facebook
account, I know you're
running some of these ads,
you're doing Google, you're getting it,
but let's gear it up deeper.
Let's do more Facebook
ads, let's do a podcast,
let's get serious, cause
the land grab is real.
And the tough thing about real estate is,
you don't know who's in the market.
So you need brand awareness.
You are trading on brand.
That is what Re/Max and fuckin',
you know, and all the, it's brand.
When, Ryan was like,
they're not gonna matter,
like brand always matters.
Brand always matters.
So, it's good to own it, not rent it.
Every one of you is
wearing something right now
far more likely because of the brand,
not because of the sales.
I don't think you walk
into a store and got sold
those sneakers, you know, you
were like, you knew, brand.
Brand.
- [Audience Member] Like
the Cheese Swizzles?
- What's that?
- [Audience Member] The Cheese Swizzles?
- That's exactly right.
- [Audience Member] How come
you didn't give us all a pair?
- Because they're sold the fuck out.
(audience laughing)
- Anyway, gotta go.
Let's go.
- [Audience Member] Hey
it's Andy Ria Facebook live.
- Live, what up.
Love you guys see ya.
All right bye guys.
See you soon.
Thank you, thank you
man, thank you brother.
- What's your overall message.
Not just today, but when you --
- Macro?
- Yeah.
- 400 trillion to one,
was my overall message.
I just can't believe that
I'm looking right at you,
camera, that we don't take advantage
of the fact that we're people.
It's 400 trillion to one
to even become a person.
My overall message is to squeeze
this thing for all it's got,
and hey the Internet, has
come along, and for everybody
who's sitting and watching this right now,
and who's in a job that they
hate, the fact that they
can still pay their mortgage,
their college loans,
or their kids' schools,
but then from 7:00 PM
to two in the morning,
sell stuff on Ebay, start
a vlog, start a podcast, this is real.
This is very real.
People are gonna say, oh, ah.
It's real.
I came from nothing,
and millions of people
have come from nothing on
the back of the Internet.
- Loaded question.
What is the truth about
college for children.
- Are you gonna pay for his college?
- Yes I am.
- Well then take your
four year vacation bro.
(audience laughing)
- Just kidding.
- I mean, look, look, I think,
look, the, college thing
is very very very difficult for me.
I wish I actually was a great student.
I wish I went to Harvard.
Because I think I could
impact more people.
I think most people think
my point on view on college
is because I was a shit student
and went to a shit college
and became successful.
My point of view on college
is based on unemotional math.
The math is broken.
We went through a 50, 60 year period
where going to college was ROI positive.
If you went to college
and got a piece of paper,
you would then be able to get
the return on that investment
because that's how the world worked,
and we were in the era of
corporations having the control.
That's not exist.
Do you need, do you need a
degree for certain professions?
If you want to be a doctor,
lawyer, I understand all that.
But, college is, will he become
a well-rounded young man,
and like all the social
things, let him go tour
fucking Europe for three
months, he'll be way more
well-rounded and worldly
than sitting in a fucking
dorm room playing fucking Call of Duty.
- Well you just wanna warn us.
Thank you Gary.
- You're welcome.
Love you guys see ya!
Like literally for the
last, probably year now,
I'd say, I've been
dreaming about this call,
there's not been anything that
is gonna disrupt marketing
to the level of that voices, since social,
and so I'm just excited to
be at the forefront of it.
- Where'd this whole idea
come about, Agent 2021.
I heard there was --
- You're gonna love this.
- Kay.
- Agent 2021.
- Yes.
I recap this nation event.
- Here's what I can tell.
It's going well.
We're in the middle of it right now,
for a first-time event, it's grand, right,
it's like a stadium, like, I think my team
did an incredible job,
I'm sure we'll recap
some of the strengths,
some of the weaknesses,
here's what I can tell you.
The 2019 version of this event,
is gonna be pretty gangster.
- Typical advice to all
this audience that would
you know like to see you
in like role model stuff.
- Patience.
Fucking patience.
Patience and self-esteem.
That's what I give a shit about.
I guess my punch line is,
- Yes.
- This next generation,
is gonna destroy, destroy 40 to 50%
of the establishment,
because that establishment
didn't know how to speak to that.
But now these kids live
100% on their phone,
which means that if
you're not in Instagram
and Snapchat, you don't exist.
Brands that are growing
at an extreme rapid rate,
are spending on Facebook and Instagram,
and brands that are declining
at an extreme rapid rate,
are disproportionately
spending money on television.
There's nothing else to say.
That's data.
It's just about perspective on this shit.
You have no choice.
- Yeah.
No absolutely.
- What, you gonna dwell
about 2000 fucking eight?
For how long?
You won't get your shit
together unless you understand
what the fuck is actually happening here.
And what's actually happening
here, is we're looking
through the greatest
fucking time of all time,
because we are fucking
live on video on Facebook.
Do you guys understand how
ridiculous the opportunity is?
Please take advantage of it.
So many people wasting the opportunity.
Because it takes a little success,
and you're not really fucking squeezing.
My whole keynote this morning
was a weird vibe, I was like,
we're not fucking squeezing it enough.
Fucking squeeze it Canada!
(excited chatter)
- So I feel like the cooler
thing for me to see throughout
the day was like, that,
created this, and it
got people here, but
the value that they got
out of what we provided,
and then they left
and they were like --
- What you guys, the core of
what people felt about what
you guys did, and then what our
employees did, it was great.
All right.
Thank you guys.
Bye.
(mellow music)
- Just another day at the office.
(turn signal ticking)
- My why is really like, gratitude.
Almost guilt.
I feel like I was gifted all this shit,
and I feel like --
- [Friend] Gotta give back, right?
I, I get you.
- 100 percent.
- [Friend] Talk about what
gets you up, like every day.
- 100%.
Legacy.
So one thing I'm fascinated by
with realtors, is the recall.
If I told the three of you, four of you,
my favorite move, my favorite move,
I think you guys sell
a home and you're out.
It's like you hooked up with
a pretty girl and you're out.
I think if you went and sent
someone a $200 gift basket,
18 months, not a year,
after you sold their home,
and said, hey, I was
thinking about you, so hoping
that you're in love with
the home as you were,
a year a half ago.
That's it.
They're gonna get that gift
basket and be like, the fuck?
And then, three weeks
later, their aunt's gonna
come over and say they're selling a home,
and they're gonna say,
you know you fucking have
to use, no, when I tell you
nobody does it, for real.
(audience cheering)
- He still has a voice.
- I don't, I don't know
how much of a voice I have,
but I will say this.
First of all, I wanna
thank Tom for coming up,
Brian, I see you in the corner
there, you're hair's getting
a little puffier, which I like.
It's the humidity!
I knew it!
I wanna thank you too bro,
and you're whole team,
I mean you're whole team's got great hair.
I, thank you guys all so much
for coming out, you know,
you guys being here has
given our team back home
an obnoxious amount of confidence.
And what we're gonna
do with this next year.
I wanna just thank
everybody for coming out,
I think there was a lot of value today,
most of all, I hope you heed
the content that you consumed,
there's a lot of winners in
this room, and I think winners
are the most vulnerable,
cause they're leaving a lot
on the table because they're
winning, and so I hope
that's the theme that a
lot of people left with.
But most of all, just thank you so much,
I wish you guys health,
because everything else
is controllable.
I love you more bro.
Thanks for being here.
And I hope you have a good night.
Take care.
Thanks, cheers!
- [Woman] Long day?
- Long day.
(mellow music)